hi guys today I'm back playing another
episode of inside we're nearing the end
and I can't wait to find out what the
secret is behind all of this now let's
just carry on get right to it I think
the secret to this is I need to time it
so right did I actually
today I'm doing okay I think this should
work maybe
oh gosh oh wow I thought I was gonna get
it's gone psychedelic is that because I
made the hairs or something Oh God oh
but it wasn't good enough please don't
die it's ok I think that's what was with
steer the music changed so seems like
that that's what we're supposed to be
yes perfect ok
we got one of these foul things
Oh get back right I don't want to kill
as a little boy oh ok ok we're making
progress
oh crap
it's more these people I'm sorry people
I just let that let the things wait are
they are they even people they just they
ain't let my dummies they've got like
things in their heads wait are any of
them people or I don't understand Oh
well that was amazed you do you
backwards hey this is faster come on
come on come on come on Kandra oh yes
just did it did this game it like it's
on the verge being annoying cuz it's
suit if you cool cow cow
we're gonna be safe now oh I've know at
least safe for the time being she can't
really be safe here can you buy safe I
think so i think i'm inside which means
i'm safe why does the music sound all
nice and happy because we know that's
not the case right let's go in here
maybe it's just happened if you finally
got away like we got away how long look
okay we need to get our boy scouts place
that dork on but that is let's get out
okay get up get out get out before you
die you can almost bare for so long I'm
so impressed whoa he's hurtin it's okay
it's okay you we haven't found any of
those secret things in quite a while
lovely because I knew what they were
little balls little balls apparently if
you find them all the endings clearer or
something but I can't seem to find it's
nothing yeah I think we found two I
don't know how many they were supposed
to be
yeah yes
made it easy ain't no match for us back
in the water no submarine it's up here
let's see if there's any secrets down
here oh there's nothing down here okay
hmm hey it's our friend kinda well she
was killing me right what'd she have
tentacles she like a squid all those
wires she attached to something she
looks dead its way that they don't have
facial features and because we saw all
those puppets or whatever they were out
there I don't know they don't like
robots or something earlier that weren't
getting killed by the pulses I'm
thinking maybe the big secret or big
reveal at the end of the game is that
actually this boy is not a boy like is
he a robot oh I did that long he could
he could be a robot and perhaps we're
just being here are human cells and
trying to make robots for the military
purposes or something and this robot has
developed free will oh I don't know
perhaps a really intelligent scientists
made him and gave him human emotions so
he's different to everyone else this
isn't wild conspiracy theories happening
right here about inside but that'd be
quite cool i mean i don't think many
people would see that coming hello
friend goodbye friend what she hooked up
to washing machine oh okay maybe she's
not hooked up in anything let's go this
goes ok let's go is this wanna go down
the war with you I don't think you
realized that he can't breathe like you
can and how can you breathe I don't
understand I'll buy even possible she's
crazy
maybe she's not even a girl you ever
thought of that maybe she's a guy with
long hair oh ok oh my gosh she's scary
let's just get away from her ok and go
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey there's no
need to be like that I don't really want
to be your friend I'm happy being on my
own all right did you do any diving
lessons I did diving once it was
terrifying ok let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go we gotta get back up
oh my god she don't not stay in a chance
oh my gosh she's so good at swimming
she's so much better than you oh the
cords are up to her legs so it's like
she was chained up or something tied up
was it buttoned down oh she's so
aggressive she's like grabbing us by the
back of the head she's so aggressive
this is strapped in
I'm scared she's gonna come oh god here
she comes okay okay and then she I would
guess she stays in the position where
she just went up to so this should give
us a bit more time to try and grab this
button yes it looks like this gonna work
oh gosh oh my god come on boy you can do
it i believe in you now just don't drown
gore would all be for nothing okay good
super he's got every human because
surely any robot could swim underwater
well no mechanical parts but there
wouldn't be like gasping for breath no I
don't think I think not just me being
silly I don't know he what do you think
robot human what is he that is a
question also he's very nimble for a
robot I wouldn't expect them to do the
kind of kind of stuff that he can do no
but this could be a futuristic game
Oh
oh now you're right Gary I don't know
you can't open it oh ok I'm an idiot he
couldn't open it because he was stood on
it that makes sense so we can jump down
here for a comfortable open it press a
button go back up straight back up I
think instead of going up the door and
then make it go back the other side and
then just tell me to the door I think
this that would work oh gosh oh she's
sick Oh her little hands she's a creepy
ok and then I met Coco back here Hey
look good ok yeah it should give us more
time we can't look for any secrets cuz
I'm just trying to get away from her
thank goodness I'm free yes so good now
what do we do under you
Oh Tenno gave me out of the water oh oh
oh why does she scare me like that what
do i do nothing like a do tonight should
I just hug her she's gonna kill me but
I'm still alive understand certain live
what is she doing to me like why does
she even want me I let you spammed the
keyboard there night I'm dead but but
it's not bringing me back it's like that
supposed to happen is she just taking me
somewhere is here robot so he can die
what is she putting in my belly
what is in my belly what is in my belly
I'm so confused oh hey hey fishies it's
a cord so am ia robot maybe my theory
wasn't so far-fetched after all what are
these fish doing they eating me I am NOT
fish food I am robot or human or
something how the hell is he still alive
what I don't understand what am i doing
how am I still alive what is this brick
bright light and are these dead scuba
divers so I'm like her now I can breathe
underwater and I got I got a school of
fish behind me Z this is cool what
there's so many dead people into here
while I but it looks like they're
wearing scuba gear
so it doesn't look like they died
because of the water maybe that girl was
kidding me well but she didn't kill us
oh that's creepy that just came up
I'm so confused maybe this is where they
were doing their experiments when they
were first building robots or playing
with the mind control stuff and
so
they flooded it themselves
oh yeah I forget we don't need to go
towards the light anymore we r mo men we
can breathe underwater I'm so confused
how does changing that to us so this
whole time she wasn't trying to kill us
she was trying to give us super powers
cuz that's pretty cool I can deal with
that super powers Oh what's this
should we go straight down want to find
out the secrets these fish is so cute
they think I'm like their mom or
something ok fish come with me come on
patient let's go
oh oh that took a while the fish
couldn't come oh oh that's the body oh
that was nice not not nice oh oh that
was close
okay what's up here I'm so confused hey
little water rat you sooo cute you're so
cute good what was that on the bed oh no
if I ever want to know what all this
stuff is oh I have a feeling we don't
want to be in the light because you're
we we know that usually when you're in
the light in this game it's not a good
thing yes just as I suspected what does
that do oh okay I'm moving this I didn't
really know why they to give me more
protection elsewhere maybe always moving
upwards so I guess would be closer to
the light which means i'll have a more
no oh I see you so much okay okay they
were doing things we're making progress
this is good oh girl I don't know why
it's just like that jump and yeah
is that more water well this we don't
have to be scared of that girl anymore
and you know we can swim underwater
that's something I've always wanted to
do ever since I was a little girl just
wanted to swim underwater because I
learned how to swim underwater before I
learn to swim does that make sense I
couldn't swim on the top of the water I
could only swim underwater hey fish why
are you here this isn't the see this is
just a big bucket of water why are you
even here you need to get out i'll save
you gotta save myself first
hmm what's this wait what the bloody
hell guys the water's up there can you
see and there's people hanging on to the
leads I'm so confused the water's up
there where's gravity I don't understand
how is that possible this game baffles
me oh wait what is that button d okay
chick chick chick chick Oh water again
my video tape remember why they were a
thing video tapes yeah there's me Majel
dude oh I told you I'd save you fishes I
told you I'd save you come on guys why
did I do that oh yes I can get back up
if I want to we haven't seen the
minecraft wool hats this this episode
what what wait can I move this No ah now
bad not bad okay where do we put this
though my warm I supposed to do this do
I need you to be up the ladder it's just
flying through this way no ok let's try
again just one more time see if you work
put you on a very edge and she just fly
fly up is that how you work I'll see
what's on it maybe it's cuz I'm too
heavy so maybe I should jump off yeah
maybe I'll just let you do it on your
own cuz I don't need to be on you sweet
it worked it's cuz he was too heavy ok
no no
can you get up there you think and then
I close this again so you stay up there
yep sweet progress this game it is kind
of frustrating because sometimes it can
be really difficult but then when you
get it right if you'll feel superior you
feel like you have brains and it's good
feeling I like having brains hey fish
why haven't you left this time cure it's
gotta be boring in here just there's
nothing there don't imagine it gets
washed spray often but whatever it's
your choice it's your life little fish
so we've got this big one so maybe if we
put this one on to this one so we've got
two going nice what is this I'm so
confused we're now in the ceiling water
and there's people for their twitching
people with no this game is just getting
weirder and what I love it but it's
getting so weird i just don't understand
hey i don't understand girl if it was
worms all over them what's going on so
this is a big machine and I'm
dismantling it for one reason or another
oh ok let's go inside
he never seems all that wet when he gets
out the water he doesn't leave any drips
or anything I don't know what that means
I don't even know what I'm trying to
point out I'm just saying yes go back
this way seems like there's more these
people
so anything actually up here there oh
there's a box okay huge box and huge
shelves I mean how old do you think this
boy is supposed to be
and
this is not good uh-oh he saw me I'm
busted I'm busted sorry okay maybe I
should just stop I thought maybe I could
shuffle you know like a toy story and
they hide under there under the Kona
that I kept a shepherd but obviously not
now it's not like that this is not toy
story
that was a weird noise to me
ok
so maybe it is for what's and they are
shipping them off in bulk to people who
need them
so strange
I don't get why I went that way there
because this door was already open I
don't know oh well the water's up on the
ceiling again there's people watching
maybe this inverts the water only needs
to go higher or lower yeah it does
I'm so glad we can breathe underwater
now it makes things a lot less tense I
lot not more peaceful away so how are
you from the store hmm the need to jump
can i push the ladder that would be the
logical engine I am completely stopped
guys so I'm gonna have to leave it there
but I think the next episode is going to
be the end of the game I think we're
gonna finally find out what is happening
so give this a thumbs up if you enjoyed
this episode and you're looking forward
to the next one do you think that he is
a robot perhaps or is he just a little
boy dance reading far too much into this
let me know in the comments below but as
always no spoilers have a lovely very
big bye oh all the dogs Shh be quiet be
quiet
uh they're gonna hear this did they hear
that today nothing up there I want to
try and find it all the secrets as well
because I hate